[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous Bienvenue
c'est Science Publique votre rendez-vous
quotidien de débat et de reportage sur
Public Sénat vous le savez la promesse
est dans le titre de l'émission donner
du sens à l'actualité se mettre au
service du public vous proposez des clés
de compréhension des mutations de notre
société et voici le sommaire de ce 21
juin Gérald Darmanin annonce la
dissolution des soulèvements de la terre
en dans ce groupement responsable des
violences perpétrées lors de
manifestations contre la ligne
ferroviaire Lyon-Turin ce weekend ou
alors la mégavacide de Sainte-Soline
c'était fin mars quel est ce mouvement
qui n'a pas d'existence légale a-t-il
incité à la violence au nom de l'urgence
climatique pourquoi le ministre de
l'Intérieur en fait il un cheval de
bataille réponse dans une minute et puis
pour notre second débat c'est un accord
historique que je vous propose de
décrypter lundi après 15 ans de
tractations les pays membres de l'ONU
ont adopté un traité international pour
protéger la haute mer pour John Kerry
envahit spécial des États-Unis pour le
climat il était temps
de l'oxygène que nous respirons du moins
aujourd'hui provient de l'océan et dans
plus de 500 endroits différents de la
planète certaines parties de l'océan
sont des zones mortes ou rien ne pousse
ou il n'y a pas d'oxygène
ce traité est-il suffisamment ambitieux
la France en leur ratifiant va-t-elle
abandonner la surpêche et les
extractions minières pourquoi l'océan
est-il un acteur majeur de la lutte
contre le réchauffement ne ratez pas
l'analyse de nos experts dans trois
quarts d'heure mais d'abord l'histoire
d'un col
lectif T1 sur la ZAD de
Notre-Dame-des-Landes et c'est Nadia
Lorjou qui nous la raconte cette
histoire
le collectif des soulèvements de la
terre s'est créé il y a deux ans après
l'occupation de Notre-Dame-des-Landes il
regroupe des associations des syndicats
des organisations qui agissent pour
l'écologie et la protection de
l'environnement parfois de manière
radicale comme ici en mars contre la
méga bassine de Sainte-Soline ou encore
le week-end dernier dans la vallée de la
Maurienne contre la ligne Lyon-Turin
souvent la contestation est violente les
manifestations virtent à l'affrontement
les actes qualifiés d'éco-terrorisme par
le ministre de l'Intérieur qui a annoncé
hier le décret de dissolution il a été
signé ce matin en conseil des ministres
cette tentation qui reviendrait à
légitimer le recours à la violence pour
une idée pour un combat cette tentation
là nous devons la combattre dans l'État
de droit dans la société française le
recours à la violence n'est jamais
légitime la procédure de dissolution a
été accélérée après la détérioration
d'une exploitation maraîchère en
Loire-Atlantique précisément des
cultures économes en eau qui avait
vocation à préparer la transition
écologique du maraîchage une dissolution
mais aussi des arrestations mardi 14
personnes proches du collectif ont été
interpellés après une récente action
contre le cimentier Lafarge à gauche les
réactions n'ont pas tardé à l'image de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon les militants des
soulèvements de la terre do écouté par
réprimer comme des terroristes qui ne
sont pas l'urgence écologique doit être
comprise Europe Écologie Les Verts
estiment qu'il y a deux poids de mesure
et que la liberté est clairement bafouée
mais moi j'attends de voir quels
éléments ils ont pour justifier cette
dissolution parce que s'ils veulent
dissoudre tout groupe qui mène des
actions coup de poing ça va faire
beaucoup de monde quand même en tout cas
que juridiquement suivra ça avec
beaucoup d'attention parce qu'il y a les
coups de boutoirs quand la liberté
associative aussi dans ce pays ça
commence à bien faire pour les membres
des soulèvements de la terre la
dissolution a été réclamée par la gros
industrie et la FNSEA cette dissolution
essaye de faire taire les soulèvements
de la terre c'est une veine tentative de
casser le thermomètre plutôt que de
s'inquiéter de la température
le collectif qui revendique 60
000 sympathisants se défend d’être une
organisation terroriste ou un
groupuscule d'ultra gauche malgré le
décret il appelle à maintenir et à
amplifier les actions
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités François bonhomme bonsoir merci
vous êtes sénateur LR du Tarn-et-Garonne
membre de la commission des loisirs
Guibert bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
président de la Fabrique écologique et
auteur de ce livre le grand malentendu
climatique publié aux Éditions de l'Aube
j'accueille arnaud-gossement bonsoir
bienvenue à vous à vos cas spécialiste
du droit de l'environnement et
professeur associé à l'Université Paris
1 Mathieu croissanto éditorius politique
bonsoir Mathieu bienvenue à vous un
premier tour de table peut-être votre
avis général François bonhomme sur ce
décret de dissolution est-ce qu'il vous
semble justifier par les violences
notamment celle du week-end dernier sur
la ligne ferroviaire Lyon-Turin oui
alors ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il y a des
gammes des violences qui qui sont tout à
fait intolérables et qui ont dépassé les
limites de la loi je vais se dire et que
l'État veille à protéger les autres
concitoyens qui sont menacés ou dans
l'endroit de propriété ou par des
projets d'intérêt nationaux régionaux
qui sont et qu'on essaye de d'empêcher
il est clair qu'il y a une situation ou
l'État doit réagir et mettre des limites
à l'action militante est-ce que l'enjeu
c'est la liberté associative on
entendait marine tantolier pour Europe
Écologie Les Verts dire ça dans le sujet
toutes les libertés sont pas nature
encadrées et doivent répondre à quelques
conditions malheureusement ces groupes
qui prospèrent depuis quelques années ne
veulent pas s'inscrire dans un cadre
légal et refuse toute tentatives de
d'avoir une dialogue avec l'État et je
pense que dans ce cas là que lorsque
l'équilibre s'est équilibre est rompu
l'État se doit de se protéger jérogibert
que vous en pensez quoi de ce décret
vous le jugez approprié disproportionné
alors qu'il faille sanctionner ce qui
procède à des violences ça c'est oui et
c'est indispensable mais là c'est tout à
fait différent c'est un geste politique
c'est un geste pour dissoudre d'ailleurs
ce qui n'est même pas n'a même pas si
j'ai bien compris le statut juridique
d'association c'est donc un geste
politique pour dire et bien vous n'avez
pas à faire ces manifestations que vous
faites et de ce point de vue là je pense
qu'il y a une erreur assez profonde de
la part du gouvernement qui est de ne
pas prendre en compte la grande
impatience en particulier de la jeunesse
sur ces questions climatiques et
écologiques
pas non plus le geste politique lui qui
correspond à et qui finalement instaure
un espèce de duo entre d'un côté des
manifestants qui ont envie que des
choses se fassent ou que des choses
soient
interdites ou ne se fasse pas et puis de
l'autre côté un gouvernement qui ne fait
pas assez et de ce dialogue là et on
voit bien qu'il se
mène sur la base de tension très forte
alors qu'il devrait y avoir un dialogue
sur les vrais sujets de la transition
économique reviendra pourquoi on
n'arrive pas à être dans un consensus et
dans un une façon beaucoup plus apaisée
d'aborder ces questions à nos Gossement
on va on va être assez précis
effectivement parce que ce décret qui
est assez détaillé il parle des
souléments de la terre comme d'un
groupement de faits alors ça veut dire
quoi ça on est dans quel faut distinguer
l'analyse juridique de l'analyse
politique l'analyse politique porte sur
la légitimité là on est sur la légalité
dans l'analyse juridique faut distinguer
deux choses la responsabilité des
personnes individus si un individu dans
une manifestation commet un acte de
violence bouscule ou porte atteinte à
l'intégrité d'un gendarme ou d'un
policier doit être poursuivi il sera
interpellé etc etc et la deuxième
question c'est la responsabilité des
organisations qui peuvent plus ou moins
organisées soutenir relayer amplifier
parfois parfois la violence de certains
manifestants donc là on est sur
effectivement le soulèvement de la terre
première difficulté est-ce que ça existe
certains vous diront ce n'est qu'un
appel d'autres vous diront c'est juste
un logo qui permet de relier plusieurs
organisations agricoles etc etc ou
militante associative et autres certains
vous diront non c'est la première partie
du décret non c'est un groupement de
fait un groupement de faits aux yeux de
la loi séparatisme de 2021 peut exister
pourquoi parce que il y a une il y a un
site internet il y a des dirigeants il y
a des paroles voilà donc ça c'est la
première partie de la question à
laquelle devra répondre le juge la
deuxième c'est ce groupement de fait
a-t-il non pas tapé sur un gendarme mais
a-t-il organisé contribuer encourager
des actes de violence sur les personnes
et sur les biens on y reviendra
évidemment en détail mais on est tout de
suite une première fois en duplex devant
le Conseil d'État à Paris avec les
nanasar qui est justement porte-parole
des soulèvements de la terre bonsoir
merci d'avoir accepté accepté notre
invitation vous venez d'organiser donc
une conférence de presse de devant le
Conseil d'État vous allez quoi tout
simplement compter la dissolution devant
les tribunaux c'est ça l'objectif
oui c'est ça on va on va déposer un
référé devant le Conseil d'État avec les
sports de faire annuler la mesure de
dissolution alors je reste sur cette
question de groupement de fait le
ministre dans ce décret de dissolution
parle d'un groupement de fait et comment
êtes-vous organisé est-ce que vous
acceptez déjà cette façon de poser la
question comment êtes-vous organiser
ben oui oui on peut répondre à cette
question de comment on est organisé et
nous on est une coalition d'organisation
de collectifs d'associations très large
donc qui regroupe à la fois attaque
extinction rébellion us for climate la
Confédération paysage des comités locaux
de la CGT solidaire etc qui était tous
présents d'ailleurs là ce soir pour une
une grande partie et on est une
dynamique d'action c'est à dire que tous
les six mois on fait des assemblées avec
des délégués de de tous ces collectifs
qui se retrouvent dans les soulèvements
de la terre et on définit les actions
qu'on va faire pendant les six prochains
mois et donc là il y a des commissions
nationales qui se créent pour la
communication pour le juridique etc et
il y a des il y a aussi des des
coalitions locales qui organisent des
actions de manière plus concrète mais en
fait on a un mouvement
qui est très dont le dont les contours
sont très changeants et qui est qui est
aussi décentralisé donc en effet c'est
c'est très compliqué de savoir ce qu'il
y a derrière le groupement de fait
défini par le ministère de l'Intérieur
et ce sera l'objet évidemment de la
décision du Conseil d'État restez avec
nous encore quelques minutes parce que
j'ai une question importante à vous
poser concernant les violences mais je
voudrais d'abord entendre le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui justifie on l'a bien
compris cette décret de des solutions
notamment par ce qui s'était passé à
Sainte-Soline lors de manifestations
contre le le projet de bassine de Mega
bassine c'était le 2 mars dernier Gérald
Darmanin
plus d'un millier de personnes habillées
comme vous l'avez vu avec des masques
avec des combinaisons avec des armes
avec des machettes avec des haches avec
des cocktails Molotov ils s'en sont
évidemment pris de façon extrêmement
agressive au gendarmes positionner
mettant le feu à plusieurs véhicules de
la gendarmerie nationale et entraînant
d'ailleurs une grande partie des blessés
que j'ai évoqués mais c'était bien le 25
mars dernier Léna Laza sur les réseaux
de sociaux de votre mouvement ont trouvé
une carte désignant les acteurs
économiques impliqués dans
l'installation de la megabassine une
vidéo expliquant comment la démanteler
ou alors encore la demande de fabriquer
des banderoles appelant je cite à tout
cramer j'ai trouvé tout ça dans un
article de Mediapart est-ce que vous
considérez qu'avec tout ça vous portez
une part de responsabilité dans les
violences qui ont été commises
en fait nous c'est clair les
soulèvements de la terre on a on
organise trois types d'action des
blocages des occupations et ce qu'on
appelle les actions de désarmement donc
des actions de désobéissance civil avec
des dégradations matérielles comme
ça a été le cas par exemple au niveau de
la mégabatine légale de grand Chaban
qu'on a des bâché il y a un an et demi
c'est ces actions c'est quand même des
modalités d'action qu'on retrouve dans
les mouvements sociaux depuis très
longtemps que ce soit avec le démontage
par José Bové du McDonald's de Millau
sur le Larzac il y a quelques années via
les fauchages de GM etc etc mais pardon
je vous interrompre est-ce que est-ce
que vous justifiez par exemple je suis
désolé quand il y a duplex c'est
toujours compliqué d'interrompre les
invités je suis vraiment désolé de le
faire mais est-ce que vous justifiez par
exemple la violence contre des
représentants des forces de l'ordre
comme j'ai dit c'est clair nous on
n'appelle pas on n'appelle pas la
violence envers des individus et par
contre ce qui se passe lors des
manifestations pour moi c'est pas du
tout une spécificité de quelques des
manifestations qui ont été organisées
par par les soulèvements de la terre
enfin on l'a bien vu lors des
manifestations interditales et puis dans
de nombreuses manifestations à Paris
c'est ces dernières années et pour moi
ça ne peut pas du tout justifier la
dissolution des soulèvements de la terre
le fait qu'il y ait eu des affrontements
lors de quelques-unes de nos
manifestations merci beaucoup Léna Lazar
d'avoir répondu en direct dans cette fin
d'après-midi à nos questions de depuis
le Conseil d'État François bonhomme je
pense que tout le monde sur cette table
est d'accord pour dire que c'est
violentes elles sont insupportables il y
a peut-être une partie de notre
spectateurs qui disent non il y a une
telle urgence climatique qu'on peut pas
faire autrement il faut aussi entendre
cet argument là mais il faut condamner
les auteurs est-ce que on peut prouver
ça va être compliqué que les
soulèvements de la terre quand vous
entendez là le discours de la
porte-parole finalement porte une part
de responsabilité ton compte appelé à
commettre de tels actes
je dois dire que à perdre de tels propos
mais qui sont réitérer régulièrement je
dois dire que je suis concerné consterné
par la légitimation de la violence
c'est-à-dire qu'une une personne jeune
qui devrait être
part à la aux discussions que dans un
état démocratique je pense qu'il y a
plein de moyens de s'exprimer légitime
les actes de violence de sabotage et
c'est quand même très inquiétant sur
l'état de notre société en fait parce
que là elle dit on s'en prend aux
individus ici on s'en prend dans un
individus d'abord à des gendarmes qui
sont chargés de la protection et du
maintien de l'ordre et puis on s'en
prend à des agriculteurs qui ont leur
force de travail qui investissent
légalement qui ont qui ont eu qui ont
fait des retenues d'eau tout à fait
légalement en respectant toutes les
règles préalables d'autorisation et qui
se voit leur outil de travail saboter et
détruit alors quand il parle de
débâchage le débachage il a coûté
plusieurs centaines milliers d'euros aux
personnes qui l'ont en espèces au
coopérative agricole qui sont regroupés
pour sécuriser leurs besoins sinon et je
rappelle pour produire dans
l'agriculture Arnaud Gossement si on
reprend les propos qui ont été tenus là
dans notre émission ou alors évidemment
à d'autres occasions ou sur les réseaux
sociaux je vais pas vous demander de
faire le travail du Conseil d'État dans
le Conseil d'État mais est-ce que ça
peut
suffire à dire il y a une incitation à
la violence sur la première question
est-ce qu'il y a un groupement de fête
je pense que c'est difficile de nier
qu'il y en a un d'ailleurs cette cette
porte-parole porte-parole parle
d'assembler il y a une organisation
derrière d'accord mais c'est totalement
légal on a le droit de créer un
groupement de fait c'est pas pour autant
ce qu'elles ont déposé des statuts ou
pas quoi bon bien sûr ce que je disais
juste avant c'était que les actes de
violence eux-mêmes lorsqu'ils sont
commis par des individus ces individus
doivent être poursuivis la question
c'est est-ce que les soulèvements de la
terre et vous l'avez très bien posé sont
responsables des êtres de violence
commis par des individus c'est très
compliqué pour deux raisons d'abord
parce que le principe dans notre
République c'est la liberté
d'association qui est une liberté
constitutionnelle et l'exception
c'est de porter atteinte à cette liberté
association il a dit solution c'est la
pire des atteintes on dit non vous
n'avez pas le droit de vous associer or
dans notre pas dans notre pays il y a
d'autres associations ou parti politique
d'extrême droite qui diffuse des idées
haineuses c'est votre droit le juge la
déjà rappelé vous avez le droit de dire
du mal par exemple de la police de la
gendarmerie sur les réseaux sociaux etc
mais ça fait partie c'est la liberté
association violence verbale dans
certaines limites qui sont celles de la
loi évidemment le racisme antisémitisme
ça ça
c'est un délit évidemment le racisme
donc ça il y a des limites à liberté je
parlais la liberté d'association le là
où ça commence à poser problème c'est
quand cet organisation
contribue organise amplifie encourage
ces actes de violence le problème c'est
que jusqu'à présent la justice a eu
affaire à des groupuscules c'était des
groupuscules plutôt alors soit religieux
soit libertaire c'était quelques
centaines de personnes au max là vous
avez un je pense que juge va se dire
voilà dans les soulèvements la terre il
y a des individus violents mais il y a
aussi des individus qui sont juste parce
qu'ils ont peur du changement climatique
il y a certainement plein de jeunes
pétris de très bonnes intentions qui
vont dans ces manifestations beaucoup
d'associations représentées jérogibert
est-ce que finalement avec ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui on n'est pas en train
de réduire ce mouvement à sa part la
plus violente alors moi je pense que la
justice tranchera bon très bien ça c'est
une chose mais prenons un tout petit peu
de hauteur même si la dissolution était
confirmée
qu'est-ce que ça changerait au fond
est-ce que vous pensez que tous ces
mouvements arrêteraient de manifester
ben non bien évidemment qu'est-ce que ça
change finalement ça change que tout le
débat public est depuis un certain temps
et maintenant évidemment de manière
renforcée va porter sur ce cycle
manifestation violente répression
permet de dissoudre les groupes en fait
ou les associations qui provoquent ou
commettent ou des agissements contre les
biens ou contre les personnes mais il y
a aussi toute une autre série c'est là
qu'on trouve on peut dissoudre aussi les
enfin on peut s'en prendre aux gens qui
collaborent avec l'ennemi aux gens qui
provoquent des actes de terrorisme aux
gens qui font des appels à la
discrimination et à la haine bref c'est
un sacré paquet et c'est peut-être un
peu curieux de trouver un mouvement
écologiste futile radical dans ces
méthodes au sein de toute cette
nébuleuse alors on est de nouveau en
duplex avec un autre représentant
finalement de ce de ce mouvement de ces
soulèvements de la terre c'est l'auteur
réalisateur Cyril Dion bonsoir bonjour
il fait encore jour merci de d'être avec
nous vous avez peut-être entendu
certaines des réactions de de nos de nos
invités est-ce que je vais reposer la
même question que tout à l'heure est-ce
que finalement les les militants les
plus violents de de qui participent aux
manifestations
ne sont pas en train de faire tomber ce
mouvement des soulèvements de la terre
qui est vaste qui est assez hétérogène
dans une sorte de piège
en fait le piège pour moi consiste à une
sorte de retournement de la vérité et on
est dans une forme de vérité alternative
c'est à dire que quand on dit que ces
personnes sont des terroristes qu'elles
sont extrêmement dangereuses
on est en train d'oublier que ce qui est
véritablement criminel et ce qui est
véritablement dangereux aujourd'hui
c'est de continuer à construire des
infrastructures fossiles comme un
certain nombre de grandes entreprises
comme le peuvent le faire je pense à
Total en France c'est de continuer à
élargir des infrastructures comme des
autoroutes comme des aéroports qui
augmentent le trafic et on le sait
pertinemment vont augmenter les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et ça
ça va réellement provoquer des morts ça
ça va provoquer des morts ici et ça va
provoquer des morts ailleurs là où les
conséquences du changement climatique
sont les plus graves et on est en train
de dire que des personnes qui essayent
d'empêcher ces infrastructures d'être
construites et qui essayent de faire en
sorte justement qu'enfin le gouvernement
réagisse enfin les multinationales puis
ne puissent plus faire ça sont les
criminels
cette cette espèce de de retournement de
la preuve et de et de vérité alternative
je crois que je peux pas trouver de
meilleur terme et et extrêmement
préoccupante et c'est pour moi le signe
d'une faillite démocratique mais
effectivement j'entends votre argument
sur tout à l'heure je reprends là je
reprends la même seconde surtout qui a
eu effectivement le on va dire le levier
juridique qui a été utilisé avec
l'État français mis en cause l'État
français condamné donc vous dites quoi
vous dites quoi il y a pas d'autre choix
que d'aller dans un cran supplémentaire
même avec de la violence
[Musique]
et bien sûr qu'il y a un choix il y a un
choix qui est évident c'est celui de la
démocratie dire que on est dans une
situation où dans un monde idéal il
faudrait qu'on se mette allégoriquement
tous autour de la table pour faire un
constat commun de ce qui est en train de
se produire et ce qu'on est d'accord
pour dire que la gravité du changement
climatique que la gravité la disparition
des espèces est en train de
potentiellement rendre une partie de
cette planète inhabitable si c'est le
cas ça veut dire que collectivement nous
devons trouver les moyens de de répondre
à cette urgence de trouver des solutions
qui soient à la fois juste socialement
qui soit acceptable par le plus grand
nombre et qui permettent réellement de
tenir nos objectifs climatiques ou nos
objectifs de la biodiversité je vous
signale tout de même qu'il y a un
exercice qui a été fait il y a pas si
longtemps dont j'étais le garant qui
s'appelait la convention citoyenne pour
le climat qui avait cet objectif là on
avait 149 personnes tirées au sort
représentatives de l'ensemble de la
diversité des Français qui ont produit
un plan qui va plus loin que ce que tous
les gouvernements ont fait depuis 30 ans
va permettre à la France de tenir ses
objectifs climatiques ce plan a été non
seulement à Moinerie piétiner démantelé
par le gouvernement mais sous le jour et
sous le sous la pression d'un certain
nombre d'intérêts privés qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que les militants se disent
depuis les années 70
tout le monde sait la plupart des
gouvernements et la plupart des grandes
entreprises savent que le changement
climatique existe et ça va les
conséquences que ça va avoir une seconde
parce que pardon vous allez vous allez
pouvoir répondre parce que on a sur ce
plateau
asseznateur donc finalement voilà
législateurs qui qui jouent un rôle dans
dans ce déséquilibre dont vous nous
parlez en tout cas je reprends vos
arguments c'est François Bonnard le
bonhomme le sénateur LR du
Tarn-et-Garonne qu'est-ce que vous avez
envie de dire François bonhomme à Cyril
Dion quand vous entendez cet argument de
vérité alternative d'aversion que
j'écoute aussi et qui s'exprime qui
largement évident dans les médias peut
s'exprimer c'est déjà quelque chose
d'important même s'il n'a pas forcément
en tout cas une légitimité politique sur
le sujet mais sa propre légitimité je
l'entends parfaitement simplement et je
crois quand même qu'il y a une grosse
ambiguïté des des propos parce que il y
a une espèce de fiction qui se croire
qu'on n'est pas en démocratie toutes les
instances on a des autorités
administratives indépendantes on a des
instants de discussions d'un conseil
économique social on a un parlement on a
tout un tas de façon de s'exprimer y
compris par la manifestation simplement
même cette liberté est encadrée il y a
des limites donc quand j'entends que ce
qui est véritablement criminel ça serait
l'inaction climatique de l'État je crois
que là il y a véritablement une
inversion des valeurs on en est vraiment
là et ce qui m'inquiète cette espèce de
montée et en plus en parler que comme
c'était un piège au bout d'un moment la
société à travers l'état doit se
protéger contre des des dérives de cette
nature il y a aucun élément spontané
quand vous voyez soulèvement de la terre
ils organisent effectivement les
manifestations ils font les appels à la
violence clairement le sabotage tout ça
l'entrave tout ça c'est clairement des
voies de fait qui relèvent d'une forme
de violence caractérisée et c'est ce que
sans doute l'état s'apprête à faire
valider par le Conseil d'État qui est
contesté le décret est incontesté mais
je crois que c'est contraire c'est une
démocratie qui doit aussi faire une part
d'équilibre des choses et il y a là je
crois qu'il y avait étalement une
lecture qui qui est tout à fait
déséquilibrée de où se trouve la
violence allez un mot de réponse Cyril
lion et ensuite je redonnerai la parole
à d'autres participants du débat
ce que je dis ce n'est pas que nous ne
sommes pas en démocratie ce que je dis
c'est que nous avons besoin de plus de
démocratie que pour le moment notre
démocratie et nos démocraties
représentatives pas uniquement en France
ont été incapables d'apporter une
réponse à la hauteur de l'enjeu aux
questions écologiques enfin je veux dire
il faut quand même regarder la réalité
en face depuis les années 70 encore une
fois nous savons que ces phénomènes
existent où est-ce qu'on en est le
dérèglement est en passe de devenir hors
de contrôle les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre n'arrêtent pas d'augmenter la
biodiversité continue à être détruite
donc si notre démocratie représentative
telle qu'elle marche aujourd'hui était
si efficace que ça pourquoi n'avons-nous
pas été capable de résoudre le problème
et pourquoi n'est-il pas logique et
compréhensible que des gens s'alarent
c'est comme si vous étiez avec des
enfants qui sont dans une maison dans le
premier étage brûle qui vont voir les
personnes qui sont en charge qui sont
leurs parents et qui leur disent c'est
en train de brûler et les parents leur
disent oui bah on s'en occupera plus
tard au bout d'un moment il panique là
il y a un certain nombre de gens qui se
disent ça fait
et la situation est de plus en plus
grave à un moment il faut prendre nos
responsabilités et tout faire pour
engager des rapports de force merci et
qui ne sont pas véritablement violents
la violence encore une fois dans la
langue française c'est la violence qui
s'exerce par rapport à des personnes la
plupart des actes dont vous parlez ce
sont des actes de dégradation
matérielles et encore une fois
posons-nous la question de savoir est-ce
que c'est ça qui est plus violent ou
est-ce que c'est encore une fois de
construire des infrastructures fossiles
qui vont véritablement conduire des gens
à la mort ce qui est véritablement
violent merci beaucoup Cyril Dion de ce
témoignage on va on a entendu vos
arguments
longuement Matthieu vrais con reste un
peu sur la dimension politique parce
qu'elle est évidemment intéressante elle
aussi autour de la personnalité du
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin
c'est devenu une affaire personnelle ce
dossier bon en tout cas ici investi à
plein pour des raisons bien
compréhensible de son point de vue qui
tiennent d'abord à sa fonction parce que
le ministre de l'Intérieur est quand
même très mal vécu le fait de voir des
manifestants sans prendre très
violemment
de l'ordre à Sainte Soline donc il fait
corps avec son institution il a très mal
pris aussi les critiques lancinant sur
la doctrine du maintien de l'ordre
depuis le confilitres mais aujourd'hui
sur sur les manifestations écologiques
et pour lui il est pas question de
débattre sur l'oeuf ou la poule 1 les
violences ne sont faites que deux
manifestants estiment Gérard Darmanin et
les policiers et les gendarmes ne font
que leur job en réaction estime-t-il
estiment-ils toujours donc dissoudre les
souleyment de la terre qui avait appelé
la mobilisation c'est faire passer pour
lui un message de fermeté et
d'exemplarité il y a aussi pour pour
Gérard Darmanin des raisons qui tiennent
à son bilan place Beauvau l'article L
212-1 du Code de la sécurité dont on
parlait tout à l'heure qu'il utilise
pour dissoudre les soulèvements de la
terre mais cet article il a été réécrit
et précisé par ses services au moment de
la discussion sur la loi séparatisme il
a déjà utilisé huit reprises on disait
allusion tout à l'heure depuis la
promulgation de la loi contre des
associations prenons l'islam radical
contre des associations d'ultra droite
et plus rarement d'ultra gauche et il y
a à Beauvau une volonté non avouée de
trouver une forme d'équilibre et géralda
Manin n'est pas fâché que ça tombe ce
coup-ci sur des écolos radicaux avec des
raisons plus politiques oui elles ont
d'ailleurs été résumé en un mot une
formule qui lui colle désormais à la
peau celle déco terrorisme qui est un
néologisme qui a été emprunté aux
États-Unis et notamment au FBI qui
définit les côtes terrorisme comme
l'usage ou la menace d'utiliser la
violence physique ou morale de manière
criminelle contre des victimes
innocentes ou des biens par un groupe
d'orientation écologique pour des
raisons politiques liées à
l'environnement alors j'ai un Darmanin
n'a pas donné lui sa définition exacte
mais c'est un mot choc un mot choc
surtout dans un pays comme le nôtre qui
a connu sur son sol des attentats
terroristes pour le coup qui ont fait
des centaines de victimes mais pour
Gérald Darmanin et pour reprendre un
autre mot à la mode il y a un continuum
entre des déclarations radicales voire
jugent-ils insurrectionnel de l'extrême
gauche et les violences qui éclatent
lors des manifestations tout ça ne se
fait pas par hasard il y a un début et
une fin est-ce que c'est une une
position partagée par l'exécutif c'est
peu dire que Matignon ne partage pas
toujours ni le vocabulaire ni les
envolés lyrics de Gérald Darmanin et sur
ce coup-là les services de la première
ministre d'abord joué la montre ou en
tout cas tenter de jouer la montre
objectant que la copie que leur avait
remise bobo ne tenait pas la route d'un
point de vue juridique mais ces
atermoiements de la première ministre
ont fini par agacer le président de la
République en personne qui s'est permis
de remettre le dossier sur le haut de la
pile c'était il y a 8 jours en conseil
des ministres preuve s'il en fallait que
Gérald Darmanin qui aime jouer les
batcope du gouvernement bénéfique dans
cette affaire du soutien plein et entier
d'Emmanuel Macron à gauche on parle
merci Mathieu on parle d'intimidation
d'escalade c'était les mots de marine
Tondelier par exemple cet après-midi
jérogibert est-ce que est-ce que vous
vous employez ces mots là vous aussi
c'est-à-dire que est-ce qu'il y a voilà
dans le dans le jeu politique je vais
reprendre où les intérêts politiques de
du ministre de l'Intérieur voilà de
l'intimidation moi j'emploie mes propres
mots et je rejoins Matthieu croissanto
dans l'idée que tout ça correspond à un
moment politique en effet et je pense
qu'il y a une idée derrière la tête de
bien marquer sa différence avec disons
l'écologie au sens large pour permettre
un rassemblement plus facile avec la
droite des républicains les républicains
qui on peut pas dire porte des des
sujets d'écologie particulièrement
importants en dehors du nucléaire et
donc il y a un aspect de repoussoir pour
permettre mon de montrer que cette
nouvelle majorité peut se construire
dans dans de bonnes conditions et c'est
ça le danger finalement de tout cet
épisode le danger qui est en train de
naître de notre façon très profonde
c'est la fracture climatique et moi je
suis très frappé de voir que ce soit au
Brésil aux États-Unis en France le
mouvement populiste les mouvements
populistes sont anti-climat ce qui
reflète quand même une chose très
profonde dans la société c'est que toute
une série de gens associés sont tout à
fait conscientes il y a un problème de
changement climatique en revanche il ne
pour eux ce n'est pas la priorité et il
se reconnaissent aujourd'hui dans des
partis politiques on a des forces
politiques qui en font une priorité très
seconde par rapport à par rapport au
sujet c'est très différent il y a 10 ans
où il y a 10 ans il y avait le Grenelle
de l'environnement tous les partis
politiques étaient d'accord pour faire
un certain nombre de choses
non je parle je parle là de la droite et
l'extrême droite pour l'essentiel
l'extrême droite et une partie de la
droite on fait un priorité très second
le gouvernement est ambigu il est entre
les deux il affiche à sa langue de
bonnes intentions mais la réalité
concrète elle est elle est en tout cas
insuffisante bon mais ça permet on voit
bien que c'est ça c'est ça la grande
difficulté parce que sur le plan de la
société elle-même on est dans une
situation on a une fracture climatique
qui est en train de s'aggraver et qui va
rendre assez difficile vous aurez
évidemment l'occasion de répondre
François bonhomme mais je voudrais vous
entendre sur le ce terme des côtes
terrorisme
aucune valeur juridique quelconque face
ça n'existe nulle part c'est même dans
le la loi dont on parlait tout à l'heure
ce mot n'est pas n'est pas cité non
absolument pas ça n'a aucune valeur le
théorisme en lui-même est un acte type
de par sa gravité vise à déstabiliser
voire effacer une société toute entière
on est on est évidemment pas là quel que
soit la violence qui a été existé contre
des forces de l'ordre mais dans ce débat
moi ce qui me frappe le plus c'est
l'absence totale de nuances alors que
les choses sont complexes par exemple
quand on dit les écologistes maintenant
je suis pas d'accord les écologistes
s'engue entre eux il y a des familles
différentes moi par exemple je ne
partage pas l'analyse de Cyril Dion sur
la violence je ne compare pas les
violences toute violence est
inacceptable ni légitime ni légale et je
vais dire pourquoi je pense qu'elle est
pas légitime parce qu'elle est
contre-productive ce que je vois depuis
quelques jours c'est que c'est les
radicaux qui se parlent y compris dans
certains médias et ceux qui sont modérés
bah c'est moins spectaculaire les
solutions qu'il propose mais à mon avis
c'est beaucoup plus efficace et beaucoup
plus pragmatique et pour quelqu'un qui a
participé au Grenelle que tu citais ou
on a fait cet effort se mettre autour de
la table y compris avec des gens qui ne
pensaient pas du tout comme nous et bien
il me semble qu'à ce moment-là il y
avait un espoir qu'on puisse avancer
pour réaliser nos objectifs vraiment
matière changement climat alors là je
reprends un argument consiste à dire bah
oui c'était 2008 le le Grenelle donc ça
fait 15 ans oui bien sûr
en termes de d'amplitude d'action mais
est-ce que la violence est efficace pour
permettre d'accélérer je suis convaincu
que non j'aurais pas le droit
mais c'est pour ça il y a un romantisme
du fusil chez certains écologistes mais
moi je connais des personnes qui sont
allées aux manifestations de sainte
Soline et qui était désolé de voir que
quelques imbéciles s'en prenaient aux
forces de l'ordre et qui nous
considèrent pas alors qu'elles sont
allées dans un événement organisé par
les soulèvement de la terre et elle ne
considérait absolument pas que la
violence est une réponse à quoi que ce
soit et qu'est-ce qu'on en face une
réponse qui est inadaptée puisque en
fait c'est une mauvaise réponse à une
bonne question comment on traite ce
genre de mouvement il aurait fallu du
dialogue et des propositions ambitieuses
sur le climat de la biodiversité
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on donne une
tribune médiatique au plus radicaux
François bonhomme un mot de jour donne
la parole après un mot de réponse sur le
voilà le on va dire quoi les enjeux
environnementaux priorité seconde de je
reprends un peu les termes de de
jérogibert de la droite
de Monsieur Guibert la première chose
c'est de condamner la violence quelle
qu'elle soit ça d'accord on lui
reconnaît le droit d'utiliser dans cet
articonstances extrêmement limitée
extrêmement cadrée la
violence légitime d'accord il y a une 47
blessés à Sainte-Soline lors de la
première manifestation 47 blessés parmi
les forces de l'ordre il faut quand même
quand on s'en propose un individu si on
s'en prend aux individus on l'a rappelé
de moments politiques et quelque part ça
faisait le jeu je crois surtout ce qui
m'inquiète moi si vous voulez c'est que
la question écologique dont on se
prévaut
en instrumentalise et je pense que ceux
qui se livrent à ces dérives là à ce
déchaînement de violence
j'allais dire desservent profondément la
cause qui affirme de servir mais il ne
faut pas je suis pas je suis pas tout à
fait naïf il y a toujours des
contestations en France l'extrême gauche
et l'ultra gauche aujourd'hui se jette
sur la cause environnementale pour en
faire un coma politique derrière il y a
un discours très anticapitaliste très
transgressif mais ça il y a une longue
tradition extrême gauche j'allais dire
il y a rien de surprenant ceux qui
surprenant c'est les groupes autour qui
par complaisance par facilité avec
parfois un sciences gênée finissent par
légitimer mais j'estimer une forme de
violence quand même qui est
insupportable dans un interroge ma
question un peu différemment est-ce que
ça n'a pas été pendant
des décennies et on va prendre les deux
dernières décennies ou il y a eu une
alternance de majorité de droites ou de
gauche une question sous-estimée pas
suffisamment on va dire depuis 15 ans
remontons au Grenelle où c'était Nicolas
Sarkozy qui était qui était Président de
la République c'est une vraie question
parce que là aujourd'hui on a tous ce
sentiment d'être face à une urgence
environnementale et biodiversité qui
oblige à prendre des décisions plus
radicales avec des conséquences sociales
sociétales plus violentes est-ce qu'on a
perdu 15 ans mais écoutez moi je suis de
département qui est parti
Glenn Royal François Hollande n'ont
jamais dit qu'ils arrêtaient mais ils
ont tous ils ont tout arrêté en fait ils
ont indemnisé l'État à indemniser les
porteurs de projets et fait cette
inconditions on a fait de nouvelles
études et les agriculteurs ont fini par
se désespérer de nos voisines avancer je
rappelle que le gouvernement a arrêté
Notre-Dame-des-Landes après 20 ans et
des années de tu te préalable ou les
travaux allaient commencer notre Dame
des Landes le gouvernement parfaites ou
par complaisance à penser que ça allait
faire apaiser les choses et renouer le
dialogue c'est tout le contrat qui se
passe regarde il fallait l'ouvrir cet
aéroport
ce sont les acteurs locaux qui s'étaient
mis d'accord je rappelle même qu'il y a
eu un référendum organisé par le Premier
ministre où il y a eu 55 % des citoyens
c'est ça la démocratie qui sont
prononcées pour c'est pas tout à fait
alors
c'était en juin 2016 55 oui oui
consultation locale
je rappelle la question était pour ou
contre le projet d'aéroport je pense que
je rappelle qui
a annoncé en faveur et donc vous nous
dites vous nous dites que l'opinion
publique n'était pas prête j'essaye de
voyez de reprendre ma question d'origine
sur ça fait 15 ans mais depuis le
Grenelle
si vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec un
projet vous exprimez par la voix des
yeux vous la violence la première chose
à dire parce qu'on a l'impression que
les nations des valeurs bien sûr qu'elle
est contestations qu'il faut prendre en
considération mais il y a une majorité
silencieuse aussi qui existe j'entends
votre argument
pertinentes la vérité me semble-t-il
c'est l'incapacité des forces politiques
et là pour le coup pratiquement de
l'ensemble du champ politique a posé les
vrais sujets de transformation de la
société je donne deux trois exemples qui
aujourd'hui dans débat public pose le
problème du rapprochement domicile de
travail qui est un enjeu essentiel
d'aménagement du territoire un enjeu
climatique essentiel et qui et qui en
plus correspond à l'intérêt des salariés
qui pose ce sujet qui dit dans le débat
public aujourd'hui qu'il faudrait
peut-être enfin qu'on achète au lieu
d'acheter 10% de téléphone portable
reconditionné on en achète 80% qui dit
ça concrètement qui dit concrètement
aujourd'hui qu'il faudrait que les
produits propres soient moins chers que
les produits sales on prend toujours
l'exemple de l'avion avec votre
propositions qui parfois entre nous sont
quand même très irréalistes mais on ne
dit jamais que quand on voyage en Europe
sur un trajet le prix du train est deux
fois supérieur au mieux au prix de
l'avion comment voulez-vous ensuite que
les gens prennent notre train donc tout
ça c'est des questions de transformation
structurelle de la société et
malheureusement je suis obligé c'est un
peu ce que d'ailleurs ce que j'écris
dans mon bouquin on est obligé de
constater que ces sujets là ne sont pas
posés aujourd'hui dans des voies
publiques et malheureusement c'est ce
que je disais sur l'épisode récent c'est
que cet épisode récent de répression
lutte contre la répression etc et ben
évidemment ne favorise pas non plus
l'émergence de ce type de sujet je vous
propose d'écouter on va revenir à la
question un peu plus juridique ça pose
la question de la liberté associative
aussi qui était un des enjeux importants
de de ce débat ce soir dans ce public et
je vous propose d'entendre Olivier Véran
le porte-parole du gouvernement qui
expliquait ce matin à l'issue du conseil
des ministres finalement il justifiait
le décret de dissolution et il revenait
sur cette notion dont on a parlé de
groupement de fait
le ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald
Darmanin lorsqu'il a présenté son décret
a présenté aussi tous les arguments tous
les éléments qui permettent de
considérer que ce groupement se
collectif des soulèvements de la terre
correspond totalement à au type de
groupement qui peut être dissous parce
qu'il est considéré comme constitué sa
présence sur les réseaux sociaux des
têtes de pont
identifiés des modalités de réunion une
appellation à logo font que même si ce
n'est pas une association qui en aurait
fait la demande et peut-être considérée
au regard de la loi comme telle
François bonhomme c'est on est tous
d'accord aussi pour dire que la
dissolution d'une association c'est un
acte grave important dans une démocratie
c'est aussi la liberté d'expression qui
est en question
au Conseil d'État qui va s'exprimer des
associations d'ailleurs sont largement
aidés par des avocats donc il y a aucun
souci sur l'exercice des droits je crois
et de les contester
simplement moi ce qui me pose problème
si vous voulez c'est que demain d'autres
derrière moi j'ai la 69 le prolongation
d'autoroute
autoroute projet autoroutier entre
Castres et Toulouse la LGV du entre
Bordeaux et Toulouse aussi est soumis à
des contestations je veux dire ça pose
quand même un problème au bout du monde
ce que veut une société comment les
désaccords peuvent s'exprimer et je
crois que là vraiment on a un point de
limite c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de
questions derrière mais ce que je
regrette si vous voulez c'est que c'est
pour ça que le Parlement doit jouer son
rôle le Parlement doit vraiment être un
facteur de contrôle de exécutif et de
poser un homme de questions qui
aujourd'hui sont effectivement assez
brutalement posées sous la forme
répression contestation mais à la base
il y a un vrai problème démocratique
aussi on pourrait aussi se dire que avec
cette dissolution Gérald Dahmane a donné
une tribune mais médiatique parfaite au
soulèvement de la terre oui mais c'est
le mandataire pose un certain nombre de
bonnes questions en particulier sur la
propriété de l'eau sur la propriété de
l'eau moi je suis moins convaincu les
personnes sur le lion Turin mais les
arguments se discutent dans un sens ou
dans un autre et donc que le question
soit me paraît tout à fait légitime donc
les soulèvements de la terre pose des
bonnes questions et c'est pour ça que
cette mesure juridique n'est pas adaptée
parce qu'au fond le débat il est
politique et il est en effet de poser un
certain nombre de sujets je pense que
les sujets posés sont utiles mais il y a
plein d'autres sujets qui devraient être
posés et c'est pour ça que c'est très
dommage qu'on en arrive là alors je
propose de rejoindre mathiasaray tout de
suite qui est toujours devant le Conseil
d'État donc ou la conférence de presse
de de ce mouvement j'ai dit association
tout à l'heure mais on est bien d'accord
on l'a bien expliqué dans le débat ils
sont pas constitués en association c'est
un c'est un mouvement un collectif donc
il y avait cette conférence de presse
Mathias vous y avez assisté et il y
avait un certain nombre de personnalités
qui étaient présentes on vous propose de
conclure un peu notre débat pour nous
dire ce qui s'y est dit qui a réagi on
vous écoute
bien écoutez c'était une conférence de
presse je pense pour montrer que la
mobilisation est toujours là elle sera
toujours présente une conférence de
presse donc d'un peu moins d'une heure
avec de nombreuses prises de parole vous
l'avez dit avec en premier lieu Basile
du Tertre qui est donc le porte-parole
des soulèvements de la terre il y a
également eu d'autres associations les
avocats du collectif qui ont donc
annoncé que ce recours allait être
déposé qu'ils vont beaucoup travailler
sur ce recours parce qu'il s'agit d'un
recours compliqué long on nous a parlé
de plus de 50 pages il se mettront au
travail dès demain et auront donc deux
mois pour le déposer il y a également
des soutiens qui ont pris la parole à
l'image de l'activiste suédoise pour le
climat un Greta Thunberg c'était une
surprise je vous propose de l'écouter
incendie pour son niveau sonore au lieu
de punir ceux qui émettent les fumées et
les flammes cette décision est un cas
d'école je pense que nous sommes
nombreux à trouver cela inquiétant et à
penser que cela menace notre droit à
manifester
la classe politique également était là
il y avait le sénateur écologiste Thomas
do su m'a-t-il de panneau pour la France
insoumise ainsi que la secrétaire
nationale d'Europe Écologie Les Verts
marine tondeuillier tout son ont
souhaité s'associer à ce recours mais
également souligner son absurdité
la suite c'est quoi c'est qu'on va
dissoudre l'Inter syndicale parce qu'il
y a eu des dérapages à la fin du manif
du 1er mai et que du coup on va dire bon
on sait pas si c'est ou pas mais ils
étaient là donc ils organisaient la
manif CPE la suite c'est aussi j'imagine
je n'ose pas croire à l'inverse la
dissolution de la FNSEA qui a écrasé des
ragondins devant une préfecture qui a
mille-feu un centre des impôts à Morlaix
qui a saccagé à l'époque le bureau de
Dominique Voynet à la hache quand elle
était ministre et qui intimide aussi
menace des paysans ou des écologistes
dans ce pays vous voyez si on suit cette
jurisprudence ça peut aller loin et même
très très loin
voilà les soulèvements de la terre ont
aussi un cycle leur soutien on parle la
même profité pour annoncer que dès ce
soir plus de 150 rassemblements allez
avoir lieu partout en France et comme je
vous le disais en introduction Thomas
que leur combat pour l'environnement à
les continuer sous différentes formes
dans les jours les semaines mais
également les mois à venir merci
beaucoup Mathias donc en direct du
Conseil d'État merci à toutes les
équipes de publics Sénat qui vous
accompagne un mode conclusion un
angossement on a quasiment terminé le le
ce débat peut-être plus politique
ça rejoint la question que je posais à
Jérôme Gibert tout à l'heure est-ce que
ce mouvement va pas finalement grandir
on voit même une voilà la présence de
Greta tunberg c'est pas on peut trouver
on peut on peut trouver ça voilà ricané
dire bon voilà c'est c'est Greta mais ça
veut dire authentiquement international
donc comment vous voyez la suite en
termes politiques un mouvement qui va
grandir à la suite de cette dissolution
je sais pas s'il va grandir s'il va
s'émi était parce que forcément il y
aura des contradictions sur la suite à
donner etc etc ce qui est certain c'est
qu'on a et je pense qu'on peut tous être
d'accord là-dessus au terme de votre
émission on a un problème des mots de
pratique grave je pense que tout le
monde est d'accord là-dessus pour sortir
des problèmes qu'on a eu la violence
qu'on a pu avoir les rapports entre
patrons et ouvriers on a inventé le
dialogue social on est incapable
d'inventer le dialogue environnemental
alors oui il y a des institutions qui
fonctionnent plus ou moins bien mais en
réalité qu'est-ce qui se passe on les
consulte ponctuellement c'est pas suivi
on les consultes alors que les décisions
sont déjà prises etc etc on ne sait pas
faire de dialogue environnemental avec
des corps intermédiaires représentatifs
et légitime respecter qui puisse prendre
la parole comme les syndicats de
salariés ou les syndicats d'entreprise
ça reste complètement inventé on est un
certain nombre notamment à la Fabrique
écologique à le dire depuis longtemps
inventons ce dialogue environnemental
parce que sinon c'est un avant-goût ce
qui va se produire demain vous allez
voir les événements climatiques se
multipliés les tensions les craintes les
angoisses et aussi les violences
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire on va saisir
des juges à chaque fois ça va pas le
faire merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat chez Oliver
j'ai appelé le titre de votre livre le
grand malentendu climatique livre qui
est publié aux éditions de l'eau à
bientôt sur public